good morning everyone my name is Ali Roy
Ghani I'm a partner at Y Combinator and
it's a pleasure to welcome you guys to
this lecture and I understand it's one
of the last ones in start-up school
which in a way is really appropriate
because my talk is about leadership
which is something important but
probably not top of mind for everyone in
here you've probably got more burning
concerns as you're getting your startup
off the ground and figuring out what to
build and working through product market
fit and fundraising and so on but it's a
really really important long-term
question because if any of you is going
to succeed in building a big company in
the long term you've got a really get
good at leading motivating retaining
great people and so I just wanted to
take some time this morning to share
some of my experiences and hopefully
help you guys develop a bit of an early
mental model for how to think about
leadership at your startups so first a
quick word about me
prior to Y Combinator I had a 15 year
career as an executive at two companies
the first was at Pixar the animation
studio where I spent almost 10 years and
I was the CFO of Pixar for the last four
and then I spent about five years at
Twitter where I started as the CFO and
then I was the CEO and during that time
I had the amazing good fortune of
getting a chance to work with and
observe some really amazing leaders in
action people like the founder of Pixar
at Catmull the CEO of Pixar Steve Jobs
Twitter's founders Jack Dorsey EV
Williams biz stone and now some of the
really amazing founder CEOs at YC people
like Patrick Collison and Peter Reinhart
and drew Houston and so on so I've had
sort of a front-row seat being able to
observe some great leaders in action and
so what I wanted to do is to share three
observations on leadership that I've
learned in my career and as I said
before you know this may not be
pertinent exactly today if you're just a
couple of people working on an idea
but hopefully for most of you it'll be
pertinent very very soon so three
observations on leadership the first one
is that there's no single archetype for
a great leader
no single archetype great leaders come
in all shapes and sizes all personality
types and characteristics and I say this
from personal experience because it was
a big lesson for me I used to think that
there was kind of a single leadership
persona like a way you had to be away
you had to act in order to be a great
leader to be followed by people but it
turns out that all of the great leaders
that I work with and got to observe they
were all really different
some were introverts some we're
extroverts some were technologists
others were storytellers some were
diplomatic and very calm and others were
emotional and a little bit hot-headed
some were nerds and some were cool kids
so if you think about it it's kind of a
liberating idea actually that leaders
come in all shapes and sizes because it
means that anyone fundamentally has the
capabilities to become a great leader
but the other implication which I think
is also really important and I'll touch
on again later is that in your quest to
become a great leader in your quest to
have other people follow you you have to
be yourself
you have to be authentic to who you are
you can't try to be someone else
if you want to be a great leader you
can't try to imitate Steve Jobs and hope
that you know people will just kind of
think that you are Steve Jobs
I remember reading a quotes some years
ago from Reed Hastings the amazing CEO
of Netflix who basically said the same
thing he said for the first few years of
his career as a CEO he was just trying
to imitate Steve Jobs and he realized
well that's impossible I have to be read
and it was that simple sort of
realization that helped him become a
much better leader so you can only be
yourself in the end because humans are
very good at detecting inauthenticity
we're really good at telling when
someone is being fake and we don't
generally follow or trust those that we
find in us
so first observation on leadership is
that there's not a single archetype
anyone can be a great leader but in
order to do so you have to be yourself
second while there's no single archetype
great leaders nevertheless share three
fundamental attributes and you kind of
got to be really good at these three
things if you want to be a great leader
the first is that great leaders think
and communicate clearly and this really
makes all the sense in the world if
you're going to have other people follow
you if you're going to have other people
want to do the thing you're compelling
them to do you have to be able to paint
a clear and compelling vision of the
future for them to be able to follow and
as a company grows as any organization
grows your communication has to get
better and better and better because
you've got more and diverse more diverse
people who are hearing it and your
processes that you use to communicate
can no longer be one-on-one but they
have to scale as the organization itself
scales the biggest lesson and good clear
communications to me the the most sort
of important thing is that great
communication needs to be simple and
simplicity in communication is really is
really hard and to communicate simply
takes a lot of time and preparation
there is an example here of Woodrow
Wilson President Woodrow Wilson who was
once asked how long it would take him
was asked to give a speech and he was
asked how long would he need to prepare
and he said well it depends how long you
guys want me to talk if it's a
ten-minute speech then I need two weeks
to prepare for it if I can talk for half
an hour I only need a week but if I can
talk as long as I want to then I don't
need any preparation at all I can speak
right now so that from you know one of
the presidents United States in effect
captures the point if you want to
communicate simply if you want to you
know
express things that are memorable and it
can be repeated it takes time to prepare
another great example here from business
for me is from Jeff Bezos and when he
was asked about Amazon's retail strategy
what is Amazon's retail strategy and he
said that the way we think about our
retail strategy is that there are three
things that will never change in our
world
in other words customers will always
want three things from Amazon they'll
always want lower prices they're always
want bigger selection of merchandise and
they'll always want faster delivery
so lower price is more merchandise more
selection and faster delivery and they
he could never imagine that a consumer
would ever want the opposite of any of
these three things and that became those
three things became the pillars of
Amazon's retail strategy for the last 20
years and employees knew that anything
they did to drive those three things
lower prices faster delivery and more
selection would be in the long-term
strategic interests of Amazon and it was
clear as day
and it drove the strategy of the company
for a long long time so that's the kind
of communication that we're talking
about that's the kind of simplicity
that's that's effective so how do you
get good at this obviously clear concise
communication comes more naturally to
some people than others but I do believe
that practice does make you better when
it comes to communication and I believe
that even in small startups even in two
to four person startups as long as you
have other people you're working with
it pays to work on communicating clearly
so the way you get better is number one
to realize that clarity of thought
precedes clarity of language so you have
to think clearly to communicate clearly
and so the first step is to free up time
in your schedule to just think and try
to jot down your thoughts and try to
think about how do i express these
thoughts in clearer and clearer ways
and plan and practice your
communications this is probably more
appropriate in a slightly bigger company
but if you're standing in front of a
group of employees don't wing it try to
prepare try to have it written down if
the company is big enough practice in
front of a smaller audience get some
coaching ask for feedback all these
things will help you guys become better
communicators and there's really no
reason not to start now to try to work
on this it's such a fundamental skill
okay so great leaders are all different
but they share three fundamental
attributes the first is clarity of
thought and language the second is that
great leaders have good judgement about
people and why is this important why is
it important for you to have good
judgement about people well as your
organization's grow as your startups
grow you know before long when you get
to have 20 or 30 employees you're gonna
have to either hire or promote other
people to be leaders in the company to
be managers and directors and one day
vice presidents and so on and the
decisions that you make in terms of who
to empower as leaders in your
organization have a really profound
impact on the future of the company and
if you make consistently bad decisions
on the people that you're bestowing
authority and power to then your
authority your followership the trust
that people have in you will diminish so
you have to make really good choices in
terms of who you empower because in the
end they become extensions of you so how
do you get good at this one again you
know good judgment good EQ is probably
you know more natural for some people
than for others but my best advice here
especially again this is a few steps
ahead of probably where you guys are now
but when you're starting to recruit for
any position your company you should try
to meet a lot of people you should put
real time and energy into it you should
try to even meet people who you have no
hope of hiring because it's important to
kind of get a sense for what really
great leaders are like what great you
know engineering managers are like what
great sales leaders are
etc and just talk to them about their
jobs and their backgrounds and how they
how they came to be where they are ask
them about how they lead people what
they think goes well doesn't go well
this type of kind of educational
interview will really help you will
really help hone your judgement about
what's good and what's bad and who's
good and who's bad and don't be don't be
don't think that you're wasting time in
doing this you know you guys will many
of you will be hiring senior people one
day for the first time you'll never have
hired a CFO before don't don't cut
corners spend time meeting people and
honing your instincts the other thing I
would say is you know as you guys start
to grow your companies you're obviously
going to have to hire and recruit a lot
of people and some of those people will
not work out just make sure that you
view the hiring process as something
that you can learn from every single
time and just be very diligent in terms
of learning you know who you hired why
you hired that person what went right
what went wrong in terms of their
original hire their onboarding and their
career at the company be self-reflective
about the development of people in your
organization and your own choices as to
who you're empowering with Authority
okay last thing the great leaders have
in common and great leaders have strong
personal integrity and commitment that
means standing for something meaningful
beyond themselves and being motivated by
things outside of their narrow personal
interests
it means avoiding behavior that
diminishes trust diminishes credibility
in a leader like favoritism conflicts of
interests inappropriate language and
appropriate work relationships etc
commitment means making your work into a
life mission in ways that inspire other
people it means giving it your all
people see this and they respect it and
they follow it so how do you get good at
this well my simple advice on this one
is to try to hold yourself accountable
to the transparency
test which means ask yourself if all of
your private communications and behavior
towards others etc if all that way it
were to be transparent to everyone at
the company if everyone saw everything
you said and did would you be
embarrassed by any of it we obviously
all make mistakes but patterns and
mistakes are bad and mistakes that sort
of damage the integrity that you have or
damage the perception of integrity or
the worst of all so that is I think a
very important characteristic and
leaders third observation about
leadership so number one all leaders are
all different there's no single
archetype number two nevertheless they
have three common traits communication
judgement about people and integrity and
commitment and the third observation
about leadership is the best way to
measure great leaders is in terms of the
amount of trust they're able to engender
and the people who work with them for
them around them etc Trust is the metric
the success metric for leadership and
Trust in a 360-degree sense of the word
I would say that across any organization
the job of every leader is to build
trust trust in employees investors
customers users and so on and building
trust is both an art and a science so
the science of trust is fairly simple
you have to be right about the empirical
questions in your business you know if
you're predicting hey we should build
this product or we should try to sell to
this customer or you know we should try
to market the product in this way these
things over time like these choices get
proven right or wrong and hopefully
you're right much more than you're wrong
because if you're consistently wrong
then you know you diminish the amount of
trust people will have in you
it's almost like asking someone what's
2+2 and if they consistently answer five
then they can be the most trustworthy
ethical person on the planet but you're
not going to trust them at the end of
the day with anything have to do it
so that's the science of trust
I find that founders often get this part
right the second aspect of building
trust is more of an art this is about
being able to show empathy and good
judgment having timing good timing when
you confront issues
it's about striving for something bigger
than yourself and not being selfish or
self-centered and this is a more
delicate obviously the art of trust
building the art of trust is a more
delicate topic and again practice makes
you better but I always try to keep it
in mind
so my parting advice for you guys as you
guys are sort of tadpoles on your way to
building big companies is that as you
with every step that you take forward
try to optimize for trust as leaders
you're going to have lots of hard
decisions to make in the coming years
you'll have to fire people you'll have
to admit mistakes to your customers
you'll have to say no to people because
you disagree with them and their ideas
try to view every challenge that comes
in your way try to view every challenge
as an opportunity to increase the trust
that people have in you as a leader try
to view every challenge as a
trust-building opportunity and as you
evaluate one course of action versus
another ask yourself which path is going
to generate more trust in you as a
leader and always try to choose that
path that's my parting advice I wish you
guys all the luck and success in the
world
and it was great talking here today
thank you
you